so jetzt kommen wir zu Klötzchen gegen
die Krise steinreich werden mit
Spielzeug ja das geht tatsächlich tja
wenn man Geld nicht verschwenden sondern
vermehren will sollte man das
tatsächlich in diese Dinger hier anlegen
in Lego
im Kinderzimmer verschwinden und LEGO
bauen sich seine eigene Welt aus
Bausteinen erschaffen ach das waren noch
Zeiten doch lego ist längst nicht mehr
nur Kinderspielzeug sondern mittlerweile
auch perfekt für Erwachsene sowohl zum
Bauen als auch als Investment
investieren in der Tat denn die Kleinen
klemmbausteine sind teilweise ein
Vermögen wert selbst wenn sie nicht aus
purem Gold sind wie dieses Exemplar der
stolze Wert 14.000 Euro doch um
steinreich zu werden reicht schon ganz
normales Lego wenn man einige Dinge
beachtet auf jeden Fall sollte man
darauf achten dass man eine gewisse
Lizenz bedient also im Lego Bereich gibt
es gewisse Lizenzen wie Star Wars oder
auch mit imable Lizenz oder auch die
Harry Potter Lizenz und da gibt es dann
immer besondere Sammler die dann auch
mehr für manche Sets ausgeben also in
Versammlung finden sich oft auch teure
Minifiguren das ist ein weiterer
sammelbereich oder auch ein
investment-bereich wenn man so will bei
Lego weil Minifiguren sind auch in den
letzten Jahren weil viele in
corona-zeiten angefangen haben
Minifiguren zu sammeln extrem gestiegen
Lego als Oktober vergessen Sie
Lamborghini oder Louis Vuitton beispiele
gefällig der LEGO Taj Mahal eins hat der
330 € gekostet jetzt ist der 1500 € Wert
Wertsteigerung über 450 Prozent oder die
New Yorker Freiheitsstatue
Ursprungspreis 200 Euro jetzt ist sie
1700 € Wert Wertsteigerung
850%. und Star Wars Fans aufgepasst sie
besitzen den legendären Millennium
Falken Originalpreis 550 Euro dann
dürfen Sie sich auf über
2.500 Euro im Verkauf freuen
Wertsteigerung immer noch über
400%. solche Steigerungen gehen auch mit
wenig Geld also ein Set also ein
Beispiel aus der Praxis ist wirklich ein
ein Star Wars Set das kam Anfang 2017
auf den Markt ist EOL gegangen quasi in
Rente geschickt worden von Rente Ende
2017 es ist eine starke Lizenz und das
war ein sehr sehr unbeliebtes Raumschiff
das heißt die Laufzeit war relativ kurz
die Lizenz ist stark es hat niemand
nachgefragt du kannst das für 25 Euro
auf dem grabbel Frau kaufen jetzt zwei
Jahre später zahlst du locker 300 Euro
dafür weil es jetzt Gerüchte gibt dass
eine einzige Minifigur darin in einer
neuen Star Wars Serie auftauchen soll
abseits von Wertanlagen ist Lego schon
längst kein einfaches Kinderspielzeug
mehr wer seine Lieblingsszenen aus Harry
Potter oder friends nachspielen möchte
oder seine eigene Lego Stadt erschaffen
will muss verdammt tief in die Tasche
greifen also ich glaube im Moment wird
nicht nur Lego teurer sondern alles ich
kann das natürlich nachvollziehen und
ich glaube auch das liegt zum einen
natürlich an den gestiegenen
Rohstoffpreisen beschaffungspreisen und
so weiter aber ich glaube es wird auch
ein bisschen getestet seitens der
Hersteller sehen wir nicht nur bei Lego
das sehen wir auch bei anderen
Herstellern dann ist es ja so dass
gerade die Spielebranche und die
Spielzeug und auch die sammlerbranche
gerade in coronazeiten ein massiven
Zuwachs ja verzeichnet hat den letzten
zwei Jahren und so eine Firma will immer
immer weiter immer mehr Gewinne macht
und wer ganz viel Geld auf der hohen
Kante hat könnte sich ja dieses Gefährt
gönnen ein Lamborghini ganz aus Lego ein
Traum für alle ps-junkies doch wer jetzt
sein goldenes Meerschwein plündern will
der wird enttäuscht sein dieses XXL
Gefährt steht nicht zum Verkauf wer sich
die Luxuskarosse trotzdem ins Wohnzimmer
stellen möchte muss eine Nummer kleiner
gehen der Preis 450 Euro Wertsteigerung
bestimmt nicht ausgeschlossen
[Musik]